Hallo und herzlich willkommen zu Raumzeit dem Podcast über Raumfahrt und andere kosmische Angelegenheiten. Mein Name ist Tim Pritlove und,
Ja, ich begrüße euch hier zur 95. Ausgabe von Raumzeit und wie schon in den letzten beiden Sendungen, nämlich diese Sendung am Center auf in Madrid oder bei Madrid
man viel mehr sagen und ja, es hat sich hier noch ein drittes, schönes Thema ergeben. Heute soll es um eine Mission gehen, die Mission Juice
eine Isar-Mission zum Jupiter, die in einigen Jahren dann äh auch dort ankommen wird hoffentlich und ähm ja, dafür begrüße ich meinen Gesprächspartner. Heute nämlich Nicolar Altobelli.
Schönen guten Tag,
Nicola, du arbeitest hier auch im äh ESAG, ganz klar, aber ähm erzähl doch mal, was ist denn eigentlich dein Weg in die Raumfahrt gewesen? Womit äh hat es denn bei dir angefangen?
Ja, eigentlich, also ich wurde als Ingenieur in Frankreich ausgebildet,
ähm dann ging's nach Deutschland. Äh dort habe ich promoviert äh in der Physik,
Am Max-Punk-Instut für äh Kernphysik, das ist ein Heidelberg und äh anschließend bin ich ähm nach Kalifornien
äh für meinen ich war dort beim das ist eine Einrichtung der NASA. Ähm ich war dort Postdoc, habe mich mit den Saturnringen beschäftigt und auch mit äh,
äh Interplantalen Internstaub äh Messungen ähm
die von eigentlich deutschen Instrumenten durchgeführt worden sind auf ähm sowie,
und dann zwotausendsieben bin ich ähm zu der Esa gegangen, da habe ich eine Stelle bekommen. Äh ich habe erstmal,
das Scienceplaning für die.
Das war dann schon hier. Ähm.
Hier, ja, das da war ich schon in Spanien, also ich bin schon seit einigen Jahren hier,
Ähm also ich habe mich mit dem Scienceplaning von der beschäftigt, ähm dann mit Roseta,
Ähm dort war ich als Operation Scientist tätig. Ich habe,
die Verbindung mit den Instrumenten draußen, mit den Universitäten und ähm aufgepasst, dass die wissenschaftliche,
Objektive der Mission und der Instrumente tatsächlich durchgeführt werden und.
Roseta, die Mission, der Flug zum Kometen wahrscheinlich mittlerweile auch jedem bekannt, aber ich sag's vielleicht äh trotzdem nochmal, man guckt immer so schnell ins Plaudern mit die all diesen vielen Mission.
Berühmten Kometen Entschuldigung auf.
Genau.
Ein großes Highlight ist er.
Genau, auch ein großes Highlight hier bei Raumzeit. Ich hatte ja zwei Sendungen dazu, sowohl äh zu Rosetta, zur Mission als auch dann äh nach dem Filet gelandet ist und man wusste, was eigentlich passiert ist, auch nochmal zu.
Das war eine Zeit,
und parallel dazu war ich dabei beschäftigt. Für die Elsa habe ich als Projektwissenschaftler der ESA-Beteiligung für die Elsa für die Beteiligung der Elsa äh an dem Orbiter, an dem. Ähm.
Also das war die Mission zum zum Saturn.
Und ähm parallel dazu habe ich auch angefangen ähm ähm mit äh mit der zu arbeiten. Äh das war noch vor dem,
der Ambition äh zwar zweitausenddreizehn, vierzehn ähm,
und äh dann habe ich mich mit ähm mit dem Scienceconsegment beschäftigt. Ich passe auf, dass wir alle Software bauen, alle Prozesse ähm und die ganze Organisation ähm haben am Boden, damit die Wissenschaft,
ähm reibungslos.
Arbeiten kann. Genau, das hatten wir hier im letzten Gespräch mit hatten wir das ja hier ausführlich dargestellt, wie das hier so läuft, dass im Prinzip ja das E-Sagt so der,
und ist für Wissenschaft weltweit,
all den Missionen speziell natürlich bei der Isarmission, teilweise eben auch bei ähm
in Kooperation mit Nasa und anderen äh Organisationen. Und das ist dann so quasi jetzt auch deine Aufgabe beim Juice.
Ja, das ist noch meine Aufgabe und.
Michelmanager heißt es dann, ne.
Ja und jetzt mischen wir schon seit einigen Monaten. Äh das heißt, erst wenn die Miktion gestartet wird, wenn wir im Aal sind, wenn alles gut läuft, nach der Commissioning-Phase.
Werden sozusagen die Schlüssel übergegeben an unser Zentrum hier im in Spanien und wir sind dann für die ganze Mädchen zuständig.
Wie ist es denn jetzt zu dieser Juice-Mission gekommen? Ähm man es gibt ja immer wieder verschiedenste Vorschläge. Auch das hatten wir hier in der letzten Sendung noch mal ausführlich dargestellt. So dieser
Battle um. Wer kriegt denn jetzt den Zuschlag und wo es den überhaupt,
dafür da und dann werden Missionen auch mal wieder eingestampft. Das war ja jetzt auch nicht der erste Versuch, eine Jupitermission bei der Esa zu starten.
Ich würde sagen ähm ohne zu übertreiben die mit die Idee ist wirklich,
hat im 17. Jahrhundert angefangen, ja, als Galileo, die Galileo Mondon entdeckt hat,
weil man nutzt wirklich diese Mission zum Außensonnensystem. Man muss sie wirklich in einem großen Rahmen sehen, ja. Wir knüpfen an die Ergebnisse äh der früheren Mission an, wirklich, ja? Also ähm es gab natürlich die Galileo-Missionen in den Neunzigern von der NASA,
und die haben dort natürlich die die Monte schon beobachtet und Jupiter und die haben,
nur vorbeiflüge machen können, ja, also die die ähm und äh es war schon klar, dass diese diese Monte äh ein großes Potential insbesondere für die Astrobiologie hatten, ja und dass man irgendwann zurück
kommen sollte und ähm uns das aus nächster Nähe beobachten sollte.
Warum war das so klar, dass diese Monde da eine besondere Bedeutung haben?
Ähm es wurde klar, dass die globalen Ozeanen beherbergen. Ja und ähm die Daten, die man damals gewonnen hat, äh die waren,
von den insbesondere äh geworden ja und äh man hat gesehen, dass es dort eine Induktion geben sollte. Das ist eine leitende äh Schicht geben muss,
unter der Eisschicht, ja? Und ähm
Modellen legen dar, dass wir globalen,
äh aus salzigem Wasser haben. Und natürlich
wurde auf der Erde dann in den Siebzigern, Achtzigern klar, dass ähm selbst ohne Licht ja am Boden der Ozeane das Leben entstehen kann. Es gibt diese äh berühmte äh ähm äh Schrotten, diese ähm.
Äh schwarzer Raucher, glaube ich, heißt das, ja. Da sind am Boden der Ozeane äh wo Mineralien, äh wo Wärme ähm trotz,
da äh trotz des Films, des Lichtes ähm Bedingungen äh schaffen können, wo Leben einfach entstehen und sich entwickeln kann,
und natürlich bei den Galileation Monden gibt es kein Licht, ja, das ist unter der der Eisschicht, äh aber äh das Vorkommen von,
flüssigen Wasserbaum erstmal eine Überraschung, ja? Äh die Mechanismen, wie man,
flüssiges Wasser so weit weg von der Sonne. Bei einer solcher Kälte äh überhaupt erhalten kann, waren nicht ganz klar, aber allmählich hat man sich,
die Physik angeschaut und äh es wurde klar, dass das gehen sollte. Und dann kam natürlich äh die ähm sensationelle Entdeckung von Casini, das war 205 im Saturnsystem, äh wo man,
kleinen Mond an Celadus ähm entdeckt hat und die.
Der der der den Mund kannte man schon natürlich, aber die äh Aktivität, die äh Geisers,
Wasserdampfsaulen ähm die man vorher noch nie gesehen hatte, ja die waren ganz klar auf den Bildern zu sehen äh auch der Magnettometer hatte ganz klar gezeigt, dass es dort flüssiges Wasser geben sollte, aber,
Dieser Mond, dieser Anceladus-Mund, im Gegensatz zu den Monden ist nur 250 Kilometer ähm hat nur ein 250 Kilometer Durchmesser,
Das ist wesentlich kleiner. Äh man sollte man wäre niemals davon ausgegangen, dass solch kleine Monde äh überhaupt die Wärme behalten können über eine,
eine lange Zeit, eine geologische äh relevante Zeit ähm und dass sie dann flüssiges Wasser ähm behalten können. Aber das ging und das ging durch,
dieser Effekten der Gezeitenkräfte äh wodurch die ähm Elizitität der Bahn, des Mondes äh ein eine Verformung der Oberfläche und des Kerns verursacht wird. Ähm und dadurch,
ähm der Mond an Wärme durch diese Reibung äh und äh diese Wärme reicht aus, um äh Wasser flüssig zu halten. Er hat man braucht,
Radionike von der Einstellung des Sonnensystems nicht, ja? Die Wärme wäre schon seit langem weg.
Mhm. Das ist ungefähr so, als ob man mit so einer dicken Bowlingkugel so einen Tennisball platt drückt und die ganze Zeit hin und her äh bewegt, dann entsteht natürlich auch viel Wärme, ne.
Geknetet sagen wir mal ja durch die gravitativen
Kräften. Und ähm das war wirklich das erste Mal, dass ähm das hatte man natürlich vermutet, aber das war das erste Mal, dass dieses Modell tatsächlich mit Daten konfrontiert werden konnte, ja? Und dann hat man sich gesagt, natürlich,
bei den Galiläen Monten, er sollte so was auch Ähnliches ablaufen können, ja? Wir wissen, dass die Monde in dieser sogenannten,
Resonanzen ähm zusammenhängen, das heißt die ähm die,
die die Periode, die umkreisen, die Jupiter ähm in einem Verhältnis von 1 zu 2 zu 4 für Ayo.
Ähm ja Europa und ähm und diese Resonanzen ähm,
für Ursachen auch eine gewisse Exentrizität der Barden, die wiederum äh dieses Durchkneten der Oberfläche,
ähm hervorbringt, ja? Und was wir für die Gewinnung der Wärme brauchen. Also die.
Sollte man sich,
mit all diesem Vorwissen äh vorstellen, ja? Wir wissen, wie es bei,
wir haben auch die Titan der der den Titan äh erforscht, also die Eismunden werden,
ähm Astro ähm Astrobiologische Objekte äh für sich, ja? Äh,
parallel dazu hat man so viele so Planeten gefunden, man hat viele äh Gasriesen gefunden, so wie Jupiter, ja? Dass man sich einfach sagt, okay, Jupiter,
ist ein Aschetyp der Gasriesen.
Ja und die Munde, die Eismonde, die sind auch sehr äh sehr wahrscheinlich ähm viel verbreitet im Universum, ja. Wir haben viel Eis,
viele Geistriesen, man braucht nicht zu nah an dem zentralen Gestirn zu sein, ja? Man kann weit weg vom vom Stern sein und trotzdem geht es physikalische Bedingungen, die flüssiges Wasser,
erlauben unter einer Eisschicht.
Diese vier Galiläschen Monde, also der Dani med ähm Europa, Calisto und Io,
halt so heißen, weil sie von Galileo entdeckt wurden. Das sind auch die größten Monde, sozusagen die ersten, die man auch gesehen hat, weil sie eben die größten äh sind und die sind ja jetzt eigentlich auch so das primäre Ziel dieser Mission.
Also es heißt ja Juice steht für Jupiter ICMons Explorer, also man will explizit zu diesen Monden, man wird sich wahrscheinlich auch den Jupiter,
anschauen, wenn man schon mal da ist, äh guckt man ja auf alles, was man äh kriegen kann, aber die der Fokus liegt wirklich auf diesen Mond.
Und äh auf die Wechselwirkung dieser Monde mit dem Jupiter und mit der Mangeltrusphäre von Jupiter, weil man muss sich wirklich das System als Ganze betrachten, ja? Ähm das ist nicht so, dass die Monde äh isolierte Systeme sind, ja, die die hängen,
die werden zum Beispiel von der Magnettosphäre, von der Strahlung des Jupiters ähm ständig bombardiert, ja, die Oberfläche wird äh verwittert und ähm,
Also es gibt diese Rahmenbedingungen an der Oberfläche, die wir feststellen möchten, weil wenn wir die Ortsferne verstehen wollen,
diese Hoffnung, dass Material aus dem Inneren nach außen kommt und durch die Oberfläche kommt. Wo wir das beobachten können, aber ähm,
was dann passiert ist dann das Material wird bombardiert durch diese Ionen Elektronen ähm mit hohen Menge Energien ja und die,
ähm verändern dann die ähm Eigenschaften des Materials, was von
unten kommt, ja? Und das ist so eine Art ähm Passol, würde ich sagen, ja. Wir wir müssen wissen ähm äh das Rätsel lösen, was wir sehen, was ist das genau? Sagt das uns,
irgendwas über dem,
über das Innere der der Munde oder müssen wir schon die ganze Effekte der Umgebung da äh abziehen und und wie machen wir das.
Ein bisschen was übersprungen, also wir hatten diese alte Mission, Galileo, die halt,
nur dahin geflogen ist und aber nicht in irgendein Orbit eingetreten ist, wenn ich das.
Um die, ne, ne, ne, um die Jupiter, ja. Aber nicht um die.
Aber halt nicht um die Monde, okay. Okay und dann gab's aber nochmal einen anderen äh Versuch, also nochmal eine andere Mission, die auch nochmal zum Jupiter fliegen sollte. War das diese Europa Klipper äh.
Also das äh Europa Klipper äh wird eigentlich kurz davor oder kurz danach Juice äh starten, ja.
Okay, also das ist auch noch auf der Liste.
Genau, das sind die zwei nächsten Mädchen zum Jupitersystem.
Okay, es gab ja jetzt von der NASA auch noch eine Mission Juno,
die sobald man das, glaube ich, beurteilen kann, verhältnismäßig erfolgreich abgelaufen ist. Da gab's auch ein paar Probleme, die überkommen werden konnten. Aber deren Ergebnisse liegen sie also in dem Sinne noch nicht umfangreich,
vor. Also das hat jetzt nicht so viel Einfluss auf diese Mission, oder?
Momentan nicht. Ähm das heißt, wir haben unsere Pläne für die nicht verändert.
Bleiben, so wie sie bei der Definition der Ermittlungen waren und ähm dafür gibt es einen guten Grund. Ähm äh,
wissenschaftliche Ziele der Elsa, die werden durch,
Die werden von der Gemeinschaft, von der wissenschaftlichen Gemeinschaft ausgesucht, ja? Das heißt, wir bieten, also der Direktor äh der Science-Drektor der Elsa bietet ähm regelmäßig um ähm um,
Ideen und äh Ideen und ähm Vorschläge werden untergebracht äh.
Vorgebracht, ja. Mhm.
Ähm dann das wird begutachtet, äh technisch ist es machbar, äh ist das bezahlbar im im Rahmen des Budgets
Ähm aber die Fragestellung, die wir damals hatten für die die bleiben erhalten, ja? Und ähm es wäre viel zu früh, um irgendwas zu ändern, basierend auf die Erkenntnisse von einer Million.
Mhm, klar.
An sich auch ähm spezifisch auf äh Jupiter konzentriert, ja, auf die Atmosphäre.
Mhm. Jetzt ähm steht ja der Start auch relativ,
an, also ich glaube derzeit steht es so im Juni zwanzig zweiundzwanzig äh.
August, September zwoundzwanzig, ja.
Hat sich schon wieder.
Ja Ende August.
Geändert. Okay, gut.
Ja
Also nächstes Jahr,
Wir kennen das ja schon, äh nichts findet wirklich pünktlich äh statt und was ist schon was ist schon pünktlich? Ähm aber man kann das ja auch nicht beliebig verschieben, ne. Also man hat da ja sozusagen auch nur so bestimmte Zeitfenster, die man nutzen kann.
Genau, ja. Ähm äh wir haben ganz bestimmte Startfenster, ähm die davon abhängen,
wie die äh Planeten sich weil wir brauchen natürlich,
die gravitativen ähm gravitative Hilfe der Planeten, um,
zum Jupiter zu kommen ne und äh wir wir können nicht einfach so viel spritten äh äh nicht so viel bedanken, dass wir direkt zu Jupiter fliegen können. Wir brauchen.
Wäre auch zu einfach.
Vorbeiflüge an den Planeten, genau wo man Energie gewinnt,
also die Reise wird in der derzeitigen Planung 7,5 Jahre dauern.
Das ist schon so einiges. Im Vergleich würde man jetzt wirklich beliebig viel Treibstoff nehmen können und man würde jetzt mit der stärksten Rakete starten und man würde direkt dahin schießen. Wie schnell wäre man dann da?
Ich weiß es nicht, aber sie sollten bremsen können. Ja das ist.
Ja ja klar, ich meine nur also unabhängig vom.
Schnell, ja ich würde.
Nur wie lange wird es dauern, um mal so ein.
Ein gutes Beispiel dafür ist Galileo, ja? Die sind mit dem Schotttel gestartet damals in den Neunzigern, aber die hatten noch einen einen Brusttriebwerk an Bord und die haben gezündet und ähm,
Ich rede von JuLis ist eigentlich, die die ist bis zum Jupiter geflogen und dann vorbei, vorbei flog an Jupiter. Ja und die haben nur zwei Jahre dafür gebraucht, ja.
Nicht Galileo, Julius.
Julisses, okay, habe ich verstanden. Also man man legt sozusagen nochmal fünf Jahre drauf auf das.
Dort nicht sich äh äh das Ziel der Mission war nicht Jupiter, ja? Das war mein Vorbeiflug zu machen und dann ähm.
Ne, aber ich wollte ja so mal so den den die direkte Verbindung
bisschen ein Gefühl dafür zu bekommen, wie viel äh extra Zeit man jetzt hier eigentlich investiert und äh ja, fünf Jahre, die werden damit verbracht, äh einmal an der Erde vorbeizufliegen, dann nochmal an der Venus.
Nochmal in der Erde, nochmal in der Erde und dann hat man sozusagen richtigen Geschwindigkeit und so weiter, um wirklich beim äh Jupiter anzukommen.
Eigentlich einen Mundvorbeiflug, ja? Das ist äh das ist ein Erdenmond vorbeiflug. Bei bei einem von diesem Erdvorbeiflug.
Mhm. Dann nimmt man sozusagen beide auf einmal.
Beim 400 Kilometer von der Montoberfläche fliegen.
Hat sich die äh Traktorie ausgedacht, dass es dann äh Arbeit der äh Iso.
Der sind die Spezialisten der von Mission äh Mission Analysis.
Und äh die versuchen immer die die besten Rektoren zu finden, wo man am wenigsten Treibstoff ähm braucht,
zum Hipiter zu kommen und so viel Nutzlast bringen kann. Ja, man muss natürlich bedenken, die die die das Satellit wiegt ungefähr fünf Tonnen, ja und davon haben wir fast drei Tonnen Treibstoff und nur sage ich mal zwohundert
20 Kilogramm Nutzlasten, äh sprich Instrumente und ähm.
Was braucht.
Ganz üblich bei der bei der bei der Erforschung, ne.
Um dahin zu kommen. Also wie viel Aufwand, also wie wie viel also von dem, was nicht Treibstoff ist, wie viel ist jetzt einfach nur für den Flug äh an Bord und ähm das ist äh.
Für den Fuchs meinen.
Da was man sozusagen an an äh Navigation und äh so weiter benötigt.
Also man benötigt natürlich eine Antenne, ja und muss die Daten übertragen können. Man benötigt diese sogenannte Reaction, das sind diese kleine Räder. Das ist nicht so klein eigentlich, aber ja. Ähm.
Mit dem man die.
Ritter. Ja ja genau für man die Richtung äh ja einstellen kann, die Ausrichtung der Sonde.
Man braucht natürlich ein ein thermisches äh die Kontrolle der der Temperatur des PSKs ja, weil man muss bedenken, wenn man
erstmal zum Venus fliegt und dann zu Jupiter die Temperaturunterschiede sind äh riesig, ja? Zum Beispiel unsere die müssen Temperaturen zwischen
zwohundert Grad Celsius bis äh minus hundertfünfzig, hundertachtzig Grad Celsius. Also das ist schon sehr aufwendig.
Hundert Grad.
Äh Unterschied. Das ist extrem ähm aufwendig für die Materialien, äh Materialien, die man da einsetzt.
Okay. Gibt's noch was zur zu dem Anflug des äh ich würde mal sagen, es ist eigentlich ja relativ straight äh zu äh,
so funktionieren solche Missionen heutzutage. Man ist es gewohnt, diese Flys äh zu machen. Diese Technik ist an der Stelle in gewisser Hinsicht auch abgehangen, was wir vielleicht noch erwähnt äh nicht erwähnt haben, halt diese Star-Tracker, um überhaupt erst mal zu wissen, wo man denn eigentlich ist.
Genau, das ist, ja.
Ne, ganz wichtig. So, aber dann läuft das ja mehr oder weniger äh und auch äh verhältnismäßig Energiearm, jetzt mal vom Treibstoff äh abgesehen und irgendwann mit der Hilfe all dieser anderen ähm Himmelskörper,
man dann in den Orbit äh ein und jetzt geht's aber erstmal, wenn man ankommt ähm gibt's erstmal ein Orbit um den Jupiter selbst.
Um die Gewitter. Also will ich mal erwähnte, wir müssen irgendwie bremsen, ja. Also wir fangen erstmal mit einer Phase der Mission, wo die Energie ähm des Orbits reduziert wird. Wir sind
schon vom Jupiter abgefangen worden, aber die Orbit da muss man sich vorstellen, diese eliptisch ja und die die,
Große Halbachse der muss dann ähm reduziert werden,
und äh für die Navigation ähm brauchen wir auch diese Vorbeiflüge, ja an den Mond. Die die Vorbeiflüge, die dienen natürlich wissenschaftlichen Zielen, ja, aber die werden auch für Bandkorrekturen genutzt.
Das ist ganz üblich bei solchen Missionen, die zum Beispiel das ist sehr treibstoff günstig insbesondere wenn man die Inklination der Bahn ändern will, ja, ähm relativ.
Wie schräg zur Achse.
Zur äh ja zur Equatorialebene eigentlich das,
Planeten, genau. Und ähm das ist äh wenn man die Monden nicht hätten, äh das wäre sehr aufwendig, aber das äh Treibstoff äh angeht.
Man ja sich sozusagen nur an einem Körper orientieren kann und dann muss man mit eigener Kraft diese Veränderung machen. Aber wenn man dann halt geschickt zwischen den Monden hin und her fliegt, dann wird man immer ein wenig in die eine Richtung gezogen.
Schub äh an Gravita in gravitativen Schub von dem Mund,
und ähm wenn man das richtig einstellt, dann kann man hingehen mehr oder weniger, wo man will, ja. Und das ist die ganze Magie äh von diesen äh Missionanalysisfleuten der.
Das ist wirklich toll. An der Stelle kann ich nochmal auf äh eine alte Sendung hier bei Raumzeit äh verweisen, wo ich äh tatsächlich diese Missionsanalyse auch mal äh als solche vorgestellt habe. Ähm ist schon uralt die Sendung. Da muss ich jetzt glatt sogar noch mal nachschlagen.
Aber ähm das ist wirklich,
'ne tolle 'ne tolle Disziplin in der Raumfahrt die auch oft nicht so richtig gesehen wird, was was sie eigentlich für alle möglichen ähm,
für alle möglichen äh Missionen leistet.
Ja und man muss auch bedenken natürlich, dass die wissenschaftliche Ziele der Miethoden noch äh Vorrang haben, ja. Es gibt die Navigation, aber man muss man darf natürlich nicht vergessen, dass wir dort hinfliegen, um bestimmte Ziele zu erreichen,
Es gibt immer ein Hin und Her zwischen wie viel Treibstoff brauchen wir, um das und das zu erreichen und äh ja, aber dann.
Geometrie des Vorbeiflugs ist vielleicht nicht so genau, was mein Instrument braucht. Äh es gibt komplizierte Sachen, zum Beispiel äh Jupiter
äh strahlt sehr viel ähm also Radiostrahlung, die eigentlich unser Radar ähm
beeinträchtigen. Die Messungen unseres Radars beeinträchtigen könnten, ja? Deswegen müssen die Vorbeiflüge äh so konzipiert werden, dass wir abgeschirmt werden von von diesem Rauschen von von diesem Jupiterrauschen.
Also man kann sich dann vorstellen, wie lange die Überlegungen ähm,
bauern, damit die Traktore optimal ist für sowohl für die Wissenschaft, für die Wissenschaft als auch für die Navigation.
Und ähm ja, dann ähm die hm es gibt eine Phase der Mission, wo wir allmählich,
die Neigung der Bahnebene des Satelliten erhöhen, damit wir eigentlich die äh Polen äh von Jupiter sehen können, beobachten können.
Während dieser Phase sind natürlich dann weniger Beobachtungen von den Monden vorgesehen, ja? Wir werden mehr,
also der Fokus mehr auf äh Jupiter richten. Ähm bevor wir dann in ein Orbit um ähm,
eintreten und da muss ich sagen, Juice ist die erste Mission überhaupt, äh die um einen Mund kreisen wird, ja, also äh eingefangen.
Wie groß ist der größte Mond, ne? Wie groß ist der im Vergleich zu unserem Mond vielleicht.
Können das, nee, sie sollten das eigentlich mit Merkur vergleichen. Äh das hat einen Durchmesser von glaube ich ähm zwotausend äh siebenhundert,
kilometer, das sollten wir im Wikipedia nachschauen.
Ja. Mache ich gleich mal.
Ähm äh das ist größer als Merkur. Also äh unsere Monden sind äh können wir so fast wie Planeten betrachten, ja, von der Größe her.
Ich habe mal nachgeschlagen, also hat einen mittleren Durchmesser von 5.262 Kilometern. Das ist äh schon ganz gut, ne? Jetzt vergleichen wir das mal mit Natur.
Nicht unbedingt immer alles so auf dem Zeiger und da ist der Durchmesser ja 4800 also sogar noch größer als.
Größer als.
Und dann kommt man dem auch sehr nah.
Ja äh am,
Ja, also nach einer Reihe von Vorbeiflügen, bevor wir überhaupt in den Orbit ähm eintreten, ähm kommen wir einige tausend Kilometer äh von der Oberfläche ähm,
und aber wenn,
wenn wir einmal in der im Orbit sind, dann sind wir bei erstmal wir haben eine olympische Direktorien äh zwischen fünfhundert Kilometer fünftausend Kilometer. Die wird dann zirkularisiert. Ähm dann sind wir bei fünfhundert.
Also zirkularisiert heißt, man versucht sie immer kreisförmiger.
Kreisförmiger zu gestalten, genau die große wird dann reduziert. Ähm so wie wir bei Jupiter beim Anfang.
Mhm, auch schon gemacht haben.
Haben. Ähm und wir bleiben voraussichtlich bei 500 Kilometer für den Rest der Mission,
Es könnte sein, dass es noch, ähm, das muss noch studiert werden, äh, dass wir die, ähm, die, äh, die, die Höhe bei 200 Kilometer herabsenken, aber das ist noch ähm.
Das heißt, zu diesem Zeitpunkt ist man dann auch schon ein bisschen befreit von der ursprünglichen Missionsplanung. Man ist da, man ist in einem Orbit und dann hat man einen Variablen, jetzt kann man sagen, okay, jetzt machen wir's mal so, jetzt machen wir's mal so.
Man hat da äh da mehr Gewissheit darüber, wie viel Treibstoff noch übrig ist, ja. Das ist wirklich das Entscheidende.
Okay, aber es ist dann sozusagen auch der der Anflug ist damit auch offiziell vorbei. Also man ist dann wirklich jetzt in so einem Betrieb und jetzt äh kann man sich eigentlich nur noch aussuchen, wie man so zwischen den einzelnen Moden hin und her
hangelt, wird in Garnime der Einzige bleiben, um den äh ein Orbit angeflogen wird.
Dann nicht mehr raus. Ähm das ist ganz wichtig zu verstehen. Also wir haben nicht genug Treibstoff, um da rauszukommen aus der aus dem.
Also wenn man erstmal da ist, dann bleibt man da auch da.
Und man endet auch dort, ja? Äh
das ist auch eine wichtige ein wichtiger Punkt äh bei der ganzen Sache. Es gibt diese ähm Pleitering Protection. Das heißt, wir dürfen äh breiteren Körper einfach nicht ohne Weiteres ähm beschmutzen, ja, mit
äh irgendwelche Materialien und ähm bei den gaelieren Munden ist das natürlich sehr strikt. Das wird von einer,
kostbare Organisation alles äh geregelt äh und alle Agenzis, alle Institutionen äh der Welt halten sich daran, die Öffentlichen, ja? Ähm
Ja.
Privaten wissen wir es noch.
Privaten ist es anders. Ähm aber bei wir dürfen auf keinen Fall auf äh Europa äh abstürzen zum Beispiel, ja weil das astrobiologisches Potential hoch ist,
äh bei wir müssen die ganze Sache kontrolliert ähm machen und das heißt der Absturz ähm oder die Landung, wenn man so will, äh wird kontrolliert äh äh erfolgen. Am Ende der Mission,
die Miktion kann natürlich verlängert werden, je nachdem wie viel Treibstoff wir haben und so weiter, aber die OBIT äh dieser Orbit ist stabil. Ähm.
Mit dem Resttreibstoff hätte man aber auch keine Chance, diesen Orbit komplett zu verlassen. Mhm.
Nee, gar nicht, auf keinen Fall. Ja. Also wer zum Beispiel bei hat man äh das Ende der Miktion war einfach in in den Saturn einzustürzen und das war sauber, ja. Dann bleibt nix übrig von der von daher, von der von den Satelliten genau, da.
Ein Gasplanet ist, so, aber muss man sich auch vorstellen wie so ein Merkur.
Ja, aber bei ist die Wahrscheinlichkeit, dass wir dann Material äh unter die Oberfläche ähm reinbringen irgendwie viel geringer äh bei,
den wir haben als bei anderen Morten. Ja und das wurde alles eigentlich berechnet. Äh das verursacht eigentlich zusätzliche Kosten zu unserer Mission, ja, dass man die äh ganz.
Was heißt denn dann kontrollierter Absturz?
Die Geschwindigkeit, der Ort, also vielleicht ja ähm die die und äh ja müssen.
Aber was für ein Ort sucht man sich dann aus? Also,
Also man weiß noch gar nicht, was sozusagen der am wenigsten schlechteste.
Man muss sich dann vorstellen, wenn wir äh also nach diesen Monaten der Erforschung der Oberfläche werden wir in bestimmt Sachen ähm bestimmte Dinge sehen und äh das ist noch alles in der Schwebe natürlich.
Aber wird auf jeden Fall auf.
Dass wir nicht rauskommen.
Mhm. Okay. Alles klar. Ähm aber die anderen Galiläschen wird man dann insbesondere in dieser ersten Phase auch zwangsläufig ja alle noch äh näher betrachten
können, weil's Vorbeiflüge gibt, so ähm geht es denn nur um diese vier Galileation, Monde oder geht's letztlich um,
Alle Monde, die in irgendeiner Form.
Auch duntzende von diesen irregulären Monden natürlich und ähm wir sind jetzt in der Planung, also der high Level Planung der Mission und zwar es ist durchaus vorgesehen, dass wir äh nach diesen munden Ausschau halten.
Äh das ist etwas knifflig, ja? Wir müssen natürlich die Disonde richtig ausrichten und ähm das braucht manchmal eine eine lange Belichtungszeit, ja, für für die Kamera und ähm,
Aber wir werden Zeit dafür äh winden.
Ich musste grad mal gucken irgendwie, wie viele Mohne es überhaupt gibt, weil es ja sind ja so,
so viel dazugekommen in letzter Zeit, man verliert den Überblick, ne? Dreiundsechzig ist der Tipp, es sind neunundsiebzig jetzt.
Ah, okay.
Hat sich wohl im Juli 18 das letzte Mal geändert. Also da ist richtig Alarm.
Ähm ja, weil es einfach auch ein riesiges äh System ist. Hatte hier bei Raumzeit auch schon mal eine Sendung zum Saturnsystem. Wir haben's auch Saturnsystem genannt, weil,
Das gilt ja auch für den Jupiter,
äh ist glaube ich ganz hilfreich ist auf die beiden äh Planeten so zu schauen, als ob sie so kleine Sonnensysteme für sich äh sind, ne, weil äh im Prinzip äh äh gescheiterte Sterne äh sind, so.
System an sich, ja.
Genau, ne und im Prinzip nochmal äh im Kleinen genauso funktionieren wie das Sonnensystem im größeren und deswegen ist es eben auch so, so vielfältig ins Dämonde, auch so vielfältig, so wie eben die Planeten des Sonnensystems in sich auch äh vielfältig sind.
Werden auch die die die Ringe des Jupiters beobachten. Ja, die sind sehr dünn, die sind von der Erde nicht ähm sichtbar, aber mit ähm,
mit der Sonde, mit Choice werden wir natürlich äh Beobachtungskampagne haben, wo wir bei hohen Phasenwinkel, also wenn wir ja die die Sonne äh günstig legt, dann können wir diese ganz,
feine Körper, also das ist wie Staub, ja und wir können die die die diese Ringe äh um um den Jupiter erzeugen. Das werden wir auch auch beobachten können.
Allein schon, damit man nicht zu sehr reinfliegt.
Nee, der die ja und die stehen keine Gefahr da.
Stellen keine Gefahr da. Okay, na gut, das ist ja schon mal was. Hm,
Kommen wir doch vielleicht mal zu der eigentlichen wissenschaftlichen Auswertung äh Juice ist ja vollgepackt mit Instrumenten, elf Stück an der Zahl, wenn ich das richtig sehe.
Wie blickt man nun auf Jupiter und seine Monde mit mit diesem.
Ja, also in dieser Hinsicht ist Juice eigentlich eine ganz normale, sagen wir mal, interpleite Ambition. Wir haben diese Familien von Instrumenten, wir haben die Fernerkundung, Instrumenten auch
Remut Sensing genannt. Ähm in allen Wellenbereichen ähm im Sichtbaren mit der Kamera und auch mit dem ähm
Infrarotspektrum mit einem Laden Infrarot. Ähm wir haben äh wir können auch
UV-Bereich beobachten, auch im Submillimeterbereich. Äh was neu ist, also das ist die
Familie. Wir haben dann die Institutinstrumente, wo wir eigentlich die Gas ähm herumfliegen, um eine Space Craft direkt ähm einfach äh fangen können und studieren können vor Ort, also in,
und wir haben auch äh natürlich die die Radiowellenexperimente mit ähm also wir wir werden einfach die
äh Verschiebungen der Frequenzen des äh Radiosignals beobachten können, was natürlich sehr viel über die die Eigenschaften der qualitativen Filter äh.
Aussagen kann. Ja. Mhm.
Aussagen kann, ja? Und was neu ist bei Juice, äh wir haben einen Ultimeter und äh das ist ganz wichtig, also man man schießt mit einem Laser ähm
und man studiert dadurch die Verformung der Oberfläche, die Elastizität äh aufgrund der Gezeitenkräfte. Wir können auch diese die die.
Über die Zeit sozusagen, also nicht nur, dass man einmal ein schönes dreidimensionales Modell äh erhält.
Ja übersondere wenn wir regelmäßig schießen und versuchen die der Oberfläche zu verstehen ja. Äh die Verformung wird äh eigentlich auch durch die ähm durch das Radioexperiment verfolgt.
Also man guckt den Tennisball beim durchgeknetet werden äh.
Genau, live, ja, genau. Ähm und äh und wir haben natürlich einen Radar. Also das ist ein ähm,
Ähm wir wir schießen diese Radauwellen und die können bis zu neun Kilometer Tiefe eindringen. Ähm man muss natürlich bedenken, dass es nicht um
zu finden. Die Ozeane sind viel tiefer ja bei Europa, die sollten bei 15 Kilometer mindestens liegen bei ähm wahrscheinlich bei 100 Kilometer. Äh aber der Sinn der Sache ist natürlich auch die die Morphologie der Oberfläche zu verstehen und wie eigentlich die
ähm Einschaffen des Eises und äh der der Eisschicht ähm,
sich mit ähm mit der Tiefe äh verändert, ja? Und wir suchen insbesondere auch nach ähm ähm,
äh Füßen Wasser, was vielleicht unter der oberen Eisschichten äh gefangen werden können.
Ähm und die natürlich auch mit dem Radar die äh elektrische Eigenschaften und äh Leitfähigkeit des Eises ähm.
Also man rückt, man rückt diesen äh Mond schon ordentlich auf die Pelle und vermisst sie quasi so in allen möglichen Wegen, die heutzutage State of the Art sind, würde ich mal das äh zusammenfassen.
Ja genau, ähm verglichen mit den Instrumenten von Galileo damals äh haben wir eine viel bessere Auflösung äh bei also bei der Kamera zum Beispiel können wir bis zu drei Meter pro Pixel beobachten, ähm also zwischen 4hundert, drei Meter pro Pixel, das hängt natürlich davon ab
von wo die ähm Bilder gewonnen werden, aber das ist
Das ist die Idee. Ähm bei dem Infrarot-Spektrummeter, also Laun-Infrarot äh haben wir eine Auflösung der Spektrallinie, die eigentlich auf vier, fünf Mal höher ist als das ähm,
Instrument von Galileo damals, das war das Memesinstrument. Ähm also,
Man kann wirklich sagen, dass wir mit äh den besten Instrumenten fliegen. Ähm was es gibt für für solche Zwecke.
Das bedeutet ja auch, dass das Ding eine Menge Daten erzeugen dürfte und das ist natürlich dann über so eine Distanz, die dann auch äh alle zu übertragen, sicherlich auch eine Herausforderung.
Ja natürlich, also ähm wir benutzen äh äh wie für alle,
unten im Außen so ein System, das Deep Space Network und auch die die Antenne der Eser und der NASA. Ähm wir haben ähm,
wir rechnen mit 1,4 Gigabits äh pro Tag,
Ja und das ist wirklich eine konservative Annahme und ähm das wird sicher besser werden.
Man muss natürlich nicht vergessen, dass jedes Mal, wenn wir Daten zur Erde übertragen,
wir beobachten nicht, ja? Äh also vielleicht können die Institutinstrumente weiter beobachten, aber wir haben eine Feste, eine Antenne, die fest an
Satelliten montiert ist und festgeschraubt. Das heißt, wir müssen den äh unseren Satelliten ausrichten zur Erde, damit werdet die Daten überhaupt übertragen können.
Deswegen hier was wir hier machen das ist wirklich zu gucken OK welche Beobachtungen kann ich machen, wie viel,
wie viel Daten erzeuge ich dabei und wie voll ist mein Speicher an Bord ja dass ich noch weitere Bewertungen machen kann bis ich,
unbedingt meine Daten zu Erde übertragen.
Warum ist denn die Antenne fest? Warum ist sie warum dreht die sich nicht?
Also ähm das ist technisch äh extrem anfällig, wenn man anfängt, auf so einem Satelliten Dinge.
Redende Sachen zu haben, ja.
Und sie müssen auch ähm bedenken, wenn man etwas dreht, dann erzeugt man Vibrationen und die Vibrationen wiederum, die brauchen Zeit, um abgedämmt zu werden und dann für eine Kamera ist das ganz schlecht, ja,
Äh wir haben aber tatsächlich eine,
eine kleinere Antenne, die äh drehbar heißt, ja und wir brauen sie unbedingt bei den Vorbeifügen, wo wir gleichzeitig,
das Gravitationsfeld verstehen wollen mit,
dem äh Radiosignal, ja und gleichzeitig die Oberfläche beobachten wollen, ja? Da können wir nicht einfach sagen, das geht ziemlich schnell, ja, innerhalb von zwölf Stunden ist alles vorbei, ja und am Kloster-Coach, wie man sagt, äh sind wir nur eine Stunde da ungefähr, ja?
Man kann einfach nicht sagen, äh ich drehe meinen Satelliten zur Erde und dann gucke ich die Oberfläche. Alles muss gleichzeitig ablaufen und deswegen haben wir diese kleinere äh drehbare Antenne.
Die IMK-Bands und X-Band senden kann
Äh und wir studieren dann das Signal äh was von dieser Antenne äh kommt und ähm.
Die wir sonst nicht benutzt.
Kann benutzt werden, ja? Also.
Was äh ist der Vorteil von der größeren Antenne, die.
Vorteil ist dann, die größere Quarantäne wird einfach ähm für alle Beobachtungen, alle Daten, die wir haben, äh jeden Tag.
Kann auch mehr Daten übertragen.
Viel mehr. Ja ja, das ist ähm äh das ist die die Basign sozusagen, ja. Wir uns aus Sicherheitsgründen auch äh müssen wir jeden Tag einen Kontakt mit äh mit der haben, ja? Das wird nicht alles ähm,
ähm äh einfach live äh.
Ja, aber die ist ja eh nicht, weil ich meine, wie lange werden die Daten brauchen von von Jupiter bis zur Erde?
Das hängt das hängt davon ab, wann in der Miktion, aber wir brauchen mindestens ähm dreißig Minuten, glaube ich. Neunzig Minuten bei Saturn und äh ja fünfundvierzig.
Dreißig Minuten war's das glaube ich 5zehn Minuten schon, ne? Je nachdem wie weit er weg ist.
Fünfundvierzig Minuten. Ähm wir sind bei fünf AU. Hm ja. Aber.
Dauert auf jeden Fall. Also mit Real Time ist da nix.
Aber die kleine Antenne ist natürlich dann in gewisser Hinsicht auch eine Backup-Antenne, also sollte mit der Großen mal was schiefgehen. Aber dadurch, dass sie kleiner ist, wird sie natürlich höhere, fillertoleranzen äh haben und deswegen kann man nicht so viel Daten äh.
Ja die die Ausrichtung muss auch ganz präzise sein bei KA Band, bei höheren Willenbereichen äh ist natürlich äh eine kleine Abweichung ähm für Wort sagt
ähm weniger Daten hatte und für den Fall der Fälle haben wir noch eine umniedirektionelle kleine Antenne äh aber das ist nur für ganz bestimmte ähm Fälle bestimmt, wenn zum Beispiel der Spillskraft ins Safe-Mode äh geht.
Und nicht weiß, wo er ist.
Nicht weiß wo er ist, dann sendet er in alle Richtungen und das wird von der Erde abgefangen, dann kann man sagen, okay, ja. Ähm.
Hilfe.
Der Satellite ist eigentlich ein Monster, ja, das ist äh er wiegt fünf Tonnen, wie ich schon mal erwähnt habe und äh müssen sich vorstellen, wie lange das dauert, um das Ganze zu drehen, ja. Wir haben,
Sie sind 15 Meter lang, ja, wir haben 85 Quadratmeter insgesamt, äh also zehn5 Meter auf beiden Seite
Wenn wir drehen, brauchen wir ungefähr dreißig Minuten für hundertachtzig Grad, ja. Also das ist nicht so, als kann man äh in allen Richtungen gucken, äh sehr schnell, ja. Es muss alles,
äh geplant äh sein.
Das heißt, das nutzt dann auch die Transportkapazität statt mit einer Ariane?
Fünf oder sechs.
Nutzt sozusagen die Transportkapazität der Areale auch vollständig aus.
Wir bauen die die größere Variante der fünf oder sechs vier.
Steht noch nicht fest, womit's gelauncht wird.
Ähm das steht fest, da sollte nachher eine fünf sein, äh weil jetzt natürlich auch die Rede von Arena sechs, das hängt auch von den Plänen von Arena ähm wann die Medaillen 64 fertig sind.
Okay, aber etwas, was in die Ariane fünf in die Große reinpasst, würde auch mit der sechs transportiert werden können, ohne ohne, dass man die Mission jetzt nochmal anpassen.
Genau, das passen ja sechs vier.
Okay, eine gewisse Kompatibilität ist gegeben. Was,
Wir haben ja das teilweise ja auch schon angesprochen, aber was äh was verspricht man sich jetzt äh in der in der wissenschaftlichen Community,
von dieser Mission. Also klar, man will die Eismunde untersuchen,
schaut im Prinzip ja nach Lebensbedingungen oder im Idealfall ja sogar nach stärkeren äh Anhaltspunkten für Leben.
Irrsinniges Leben.
In irgendeiner Form,
das wird ja sicherlich auch nicht das einzige sein, also was worauf warten die die wissenschaftlichen Teams dann eigentlich so äh vor allem.
Also ähm einer der größten Punkte ist natürlich die Sinn, das ist natürlich die die Ozeane, ja. Ganz äh,
eindeutig eine das ist die Astrobiologie, die Habitabilität. Das ist ein wichtiger äh Konzept. Ähm wir suchen nicht und ich muss das nochmal betonen, ja. Äh wir so nicht mal leben. Wir suchen nach
Bedingungen, die erdendliches Leben beherbergen.
Und dabei spielt auch Jupiter eine zentrale Rolle, was man sich verspricht. Natürlich ist äh es gibt
Fragestellungen wie ähm die Energiekrise des Jubiters, wie die Energie vom Jupiter, vom Inneren nach außen transportiert ist, das versteht man nicht ganz. Ja, die die Modelle äh.
Ähm sagen Temperaturen vorher in der Thermosphäre, die viel höher sind ähm als das, was man misst und äh das sind Sachen, die man verstehen sollte, weil natürlich die ganze Wechselwirkung des Jupiters mit entmonden ist entscheidend, um zu verstehen,
die Monte überhaupt äh werden können, ja. Ähm benötigt Stabilität, ja. Nicht nur flüssiges Wasser,
Wasser ist natürlich eine Voraussetzung, aber auch Stabilität, Zeit, damit Leben,
entstehen kann und als ich entwickeln kann, Kontakt auch mit äh wichtigen Grundbau ähm äh Grundelemente des Lebens, ja? Ähm und wie gewinnt man diese Elemente? Man braucht,
flüssiges Wasser in Kontakt mit Gestein zum Beispiel, ja? Und ähm man baut chemische Energie, ja? Also das ist wirklich, was ich die Community davon verspricht, haben wir,
die Bedingungen einer Abiturität im Jubiter System als Ensemble, ja? Und können wir diese äh Bedingungen,
dann zu den so Planeten und äh rübertragen. Was wir sehen hier im Sonnensystem ist, es ist was sehr verbreitet oder ist es eine Ausnahme.
Ja und äh ich glaube, das ist wirklich die das Wichtigste bei der Mission und das ist natürlich nur eine Etappe ähm,
Für die nächsten Mietionen und vielleicht kann man sich vorstellen, dass wir irgendwann auf Europa landen und dann äh oder und dann direkt unterirdisch beobachten oder.
Die ähm in die Tiefe eindringen kann irgendwie. Ähm.
Ist in der äh also ist einer von denen äh vergleichbar auch mit dem Enzelados, bei dem also der Enzelados der Saturnmond
Fällt ja schon dadurch auf, also als wenn die Bilder äh gesehen hat, da waren ja einfach diese massiven Wasserfontänen. Das sieht ja spektakulär aus und äh ähm einzigartig.
Ähm bei den Monden ist es aber jetzt also bei den Monden des Saturns ist das jetzt so sichtbar nicht, findet so nicht statt.
Des Jupiters meinen sie. Ähm ja, doch also,
so sichtbar nicht, äh aber es wurden zwotausendvierzehn, fünfzehn und sechzehn eine Reihe von Beobachtungen durchgeführt mit Habeln äh und auch mit dem Teleskop, also mit Habel, das war, glaube ich, im UV-Bereich mit dem Cap,
War eher im Infrarotbereich. Äh wo man gesehen hat, also Wasserdampfsauen ähm die sind wahrscheinlich nicht,
immer da, aber das ist auch am Ventilator ist bekannt, dass hier nach äh je nach der Position von auf auf äh auf seiner Bahn, dann ändert sich die Aktivität, ja?
Gerade gequetscht wird.
Genau, genau wegen.
Wie so eine Zitrone, wenn man sich drückt und dann schießt es ab und.
Wurde quantifiziert und ähm,
Und jetzt also die die Indizien, die auf ein Ozean ähm die einen Ozean naheliegen, sind natürlich noch ähm,
dichter geworden irgendwie mit diesen Beobachtungen von Hable äh und dem mit dem Teleskop und einem hat man
auch, glaube ich, 215 gesehen, wie die äh Polarlichter ähm,
also das sind die, deswegen ist Jupiter ganz wichtig dabei, eine Menge Atmosphäre, weil wir haben diese hoch energetische Teichen, die äh am Jupiter ankommen und äh die werden von dem ähm
Feld von äh abgelenkt und äh die für Hochsachen, diese diese Lichter und das Verhalten dieser.
Also wie so eine Aurora jetzt auch auf der Erde.
Genau, wie auf der Erde und äh das Verhalten dieser Lichter äh liegt nahe, dass man äh die eine leitende Schicht,
bei 100 Kilometer im Inneren hat und ähm warum sage ich das alles eigentlich? Ja, die Frage am Anfang.
Die Mundaktivität und die Ozeane, das ähm.
Ja genau, nee, ich hätte lieber bei Hobby bleiben sollen. Und Kek, ja, also die Wasserdampfsäulen sind da. Äh die die sieht man, die gehen, also die die die schießen bis 150 Kilometer Höhe ins Welttal.
Jetzt sagt Ozeane, wie muss man sich das vorstellen? Also äh wir reden ja jetzt nicht so von so offenen Ozeanen an der Oberfläche, wie wir das jetzt von der Erde kennen, sondern wir reden von Wasservorkommen, die aber,
unter einer Gesteinsoberfläche außen eine Eisoberfläche, die keinerlei, also die nur Eis ist.
Ja ja ähm diese diese Körper, also die sind ähm separiert. Das waren die die oder differenziert. Äh die dichtere Elemente sind.
Nach innen mhm.
Äh die leichteren wie Eis äh sind nach oben gegangen, also geblieben. Ähm.
Das ja bei uns auch der Fall ist auf der Erde.
Genau, so wie so wie bei der Erde. Wir haben einen harten Kern und ähm ja und,
bei Europa insbesondere, da hat man die Thermophysikalische Modelle legen nahe, dass wir eine Einschicht von 50 Kilometer haben,
weniger und dann ein Ozean, das heißt flüssiges Wasser, gesalzes Wasser wahrscheinlich, was bis zum
Kern bis zum Gestein erstreckt und das ist ganz wichtig für äh das Potenzial der Avitabilität äh des Mundes, äh weil wir haben, wie ich mal erwähnte, wir haben die Möglichkeit, wichtige Elemente, Mineralien ins Wasser, ähm
Mineralien werden von den vom Gestein äh ins Wasser ähm äh abgegeben, genau,
Ähm diese Bedingungen hat man nicht unbedingt bei genial. Bei genial da hat man eher,
Laut Modellen und äh Messungen hat man eher ein Ozean zwischen Eisschichten,
Ja, es gibt, man muss sich so als ein Sandwich vorstellen, mit Fashion Eisschichten und dazwischen sehr wahrscheinlich ein Ozean von 100 Kilometer Dicken.
Also wo das Wasser nicht mehr gefroren ist, eben durch diese gesamte Aktivität, dadurch dass das Ding einfach die ganze Zeit vom Jupiter so geknetet.
Ja und Salzgehalt und auch, also das wird nicht alles durch die gravitativen Kräften äh ähm,
bedenkt oder erklärt, ja. Auch äh thermodynamisch äh hat Wasser eine ganz eine ganz wichtige Eigenschaft, nämlich dass äh die Schmelzkurve,
äh im Drucktemperaturdiagramm, also im Graben des Wasser, der hat eine negative äh Neigung. Das heißt, die Schmelztemperatur,
singt mit Hirndruck,
und das ist ähm von der Erde bekannt, zum Beispiel der Rostocksee im Antatika ähm 4tausend Meter unter der Eisschicht äh hat man flüssiges Wasser. Und dafür braucht man nur,
Erhöhung des Drucks. Irgendwann hat man einen Punkt erreicht, wo äh das Wasser einfach schmilzt. Bei den Monden,
Äh natürlich ist die Oberflächenlampe viel kleiner als bei der Erde. Wir sind bei Minus 160 Grad vielleicht äh am von Europa zum Beispiel. Ähm das heißt natürlich,
Dieses ähm der der Druck muss natürlich äh groß genug sein, ähm aber.
Der Mond muss selbst groß genug sein, damit der Druck diesen Wert äh äh mit der Tiefe äh ähm erreichen kann. Und bei
Europas scheint das zu klappen. Das heißt,
Druck wird groß genug, die Gezeitenkräfte sind da und bringen die Energie und äh wir können diese ähm diese Wasserschicht haben
die dann im Kontakt mit dem Kern ist. Bei äh das ist nicht unbedingt der Fall, ja? Da äh ist die Größe des Mundes, die ähm
Gezeitenkräfte sind äh weniger ausgeprägt als bei bei Europa, weil man
weiter weg ist äh entfernter ist äh von Jupiter und alles in allem ähm,
Es ist am wahrscheinlichsten, dass wir diese diese Sandwich ähm Organisation der Eis- und Wasserschichten haben.
Mhm. Angenommen, man würde jetzt mal einfach so nehmen und auf die äh Umlaufbahn der Erde um die Sonne packen, also unter dieselben klimatischen Verhältnisse.
Bedeutet, da würde dann einfach so ein Wasserball bei rauskommen.
Enthält sehr viel Wasser in der Tat, dass es 30 Prozent bis 30 Prozent Eisfraktion ähm bei Europa haben wir viel weniger bis fünfzehn Prozent. Ähm die Monde äh tatsächlich,
beherbergen wahrscheinlich mehr Wasser als alle Ozeane der Erde zusammen.
Erde steht man sich immer als die blaue Kugel vor als ein Ozeanwelt, aber ist es nicht, ne? Das sind,
70 Prozent der Oberfläche mit Wasser bedeckt, aber das ist nur eine Dicke ist ganz klein. Er bist ja zwölf äh hundert,
paar Kilometer, zwölf Kilometer. Ähm bei Garnele ähm wir haben bis 100 Kilometer äh eine bis 1hundert Kilometer Wasserschicht und ähm also trotz des Unterschieden der Größe ähm hat Ganime,
zweimal so viel ähm Wasser als äh als Erde. Deswegen muss man diese Eismunde wirklich als die Ozeanenwelt äh betrachten und nicht unbedingt die Erde.
Wo kommt dann das ganze Wasser her? Also bei dem bei der Erde gibt's ja auch so diese offene Frage, so war das immer schon da oder kam das von irgendwo anders? Ähm wobei ich mich das eigentlich immer so ein bisschen frage, weil das ja einfach so ein grundlegendes Element ist, wo man ja durchaus.
Also die die Frage ist eigentlich viel einfacher zu beantworten. Im Außensystem also die Erde, ja? Die die richtige Frage ist eigentlich, wo kommt das Wasser von der Herde her?
Ähm bei den Galerischen Monden. Das ist einfach im Außensonnensystem, wo die flüchtigen Elemente also erst mal ist Wasser sehr weit verbreitet. Das ist äh das im im ganzen Universum sieht man Wasser überall, ja.
Natürlich in Eisformen oder Dampf. Ähm und ähm daraus hat man natürlich hat man
der den den Begriff der Abiturität, der Abitur Zonen äh hergeleitet. Das heißt, das ist der Abstandbereich von dem Zentralgestirn, wo Wasser sich dauerhaft äh auf der Oberfläche eines Planeten äh aufhalten kann, ja?
Und im flüssigen.
Im flüssigen Zustand. Und bei den Eismonden sind wir natürlich außerhalb der traditionellen äh arbitablen Zonen, ja und
sprechen jetzt eigentlich mit der Community von einer Erweiterung der Abi-Tabletion, weil wir äh flüssiges Wasser haben können, viel weiter weg.
Auch unter anderen Bedingungen eben nicht durch die Sonne, sondern eben den Moment eben durch die chemische Zusammensetzung, plus Gravitation.
Chemische Energie, Thermodynamik,
Aber Wasser an sich ist extrem verbreitet ähm und äh hat keinen Grund eigentlich äh wegzugehen, wenn wir im Ausland sind. Sollen System sind
dabei bei der Erde, wo die Erde entstanden ist, dann waren die Temperaturen natürlich viel zu hoch und äh deswegen gibt's all diese Überlegungen, kam es von Kometen dann später äh oder hm,
kommt es vom Kern, von von der von den Kristallen von den Meteoriten, von den von den Kontroten.
Ähm er ist jetzt grade richtig verstanden habe und bei den Instrumenten ähm von Juice gibt's auch welche, die so Partikel einfangen können. Also wir reden jetzt hier wirklich von Röhrchen raushalten.
Und dann in so einem kleinen Labor auch sofort untersuchen.
Ja, das sind kleine fliegende Labore. Äh wir haben diese Massenspektrummeter an Bord. Das heißt, die Teichen werden angefangen, oder Atomenneutralen Atomen oder Elektronen. Ähm und oder,
Staubteilchen. Die können auch da gefangen werden und die werden analysiert hier nach der Sorte natürlich. Also es gibt,
Instrumente, die haben starke Magnetfelder, damit die Energie der der geladene Teilchen ähm analysiert werden kann,
Ähm und das hilft äh zum Beispiel.
Die um die Exosphäre der Dämonde zu ähm zu verstehen, ähm wenn,
Die Oberfläche des Mondes ständig mit diesen hochenergetischen Partikel vom vom Jupiter von der eingeschlagen werden. Das verwittert natürlich die Oberfläche,
setzt äh Wasser und äh sauerstofffrei. Äh und wir können dann gucken, ähm wenn wir vorbeifliegen bei 400 Kilometer Höhe zum Beispiel. Wir können diese
diese Oberflächenmaterial einfach abfangen und äh vor Ort analysieren.
Und wenn man jetzt feststellt, dass es auch diese Geysire äh gibt, zumindest selten in irgendeiner Form. Ich weiß nicht, wie hoch flogen die beim Enzelados, also was weiß man, wie weit das da rausgeschleudert wird. Dann kann's ja durchaus sein, dass sie sich Schuster auch eine Dusche abholt.
Anhand der Oppelbeerwartungen wissen wir, dass die bis hundertfünfzig Kilometer äh Höhe. Äh sich erstrecken, ja?
Mhm. Also im sichtbaren Bereich sozusagen und der Rest wird ja dann irgendwie auch noch.
Ja, das wird verdünt und herumfliegen.
Das heißt, man könnte dann in dem Fall im Idealfall quasi direkt vorbeifliegen und gucken, was da jetzt raus.
Könnten da durchfliegen, genau so wie das gemacht hat bei die die ganze Planung der Territorie wurde gehindert, damit ähm die sind bei 50 Kilometer, glaube ich, von der Oberfläche geflogen,
durch die Kaisers ähm und damals hat
eigentlich ein deutsches Instrument, äh dass Kosmik das eine Reise äh vom Max-Lon-Institut für ähm gernphysik in Heidelberg, die haben diese Staubzeichen gefangen und man hat damals gesehen, ähm
diese das das waren Eisteichen mit Silikatten
mit Nanosilikaten drinnen, ja und ähm die konnten ganz viele ähm Sachen über die Eigenschaften der des Ozeans herleiten und haben sogar dazu beigetragen, dass man jetzt weiß, dass es eine geothermische Quelle am,
am Boden von.
Äh so was könnte man sich natürlich mit Juice auch vorstellen. Äh wir pflegen zwar beim vierhundert Kilometer, aber das könnte sich das das muss man noch,
ähm überlegen natürlich.
Woran man sich ja schon so ein bisschen gewöhnt hat, deswegen würde ich das ja fast erwarten, dass man eben auch so eine wunderschöne äh hochauflösende, dreidimensionale Kartografie am Ende äh erhält. Das wird Juice wahrscheinlich auf jeden Fall leisten können, ne? Sowohl.
Ein DTM, wie man sagt.
Den Jup Jupiter sicherlich nicht komplett, sondern äh aber vollständig. Kann denn.
Kann in der Orbit um noch so angepasst werden, dass man auch wirklich über die Pole fliegen kann oder also sozusagen die Ausrichtung des Orbits noch ändern kann, um auch wirklich alle Bereiche abzudecken.
Also die Orbits ist ähm Polar erstmal, ähm aber die wird die wird so ausgerichtet, ähm äh also die Monde dreht sich äh unter die Spacekraft, ja und das hilft natürlich bei der.
Ah okay, also wie bei der Erdbeobachtung macht man einfach einen Polarohr,
auch naheliegend gedacht.
Das ist äh das einfach so, ja.
So, dann gibt's also schön dreidimensionale Bilder.
Ja absolut, also diese zum Beispiel ähm ähm also das hängt dann davon ab, wie viel,
Attenmenge. Wir übertragen können, äh ob bestimmte wir suchen natürlich nach geologischen ähm,
außergewöhnlichen Informationen. Ja, das ist ganz wichtig, dass man es gibt schon ähm sogenannte ja, wo man besondere Interesse hat, äh weil,
Region, das sagen wir uns natürlich die Geologen, aber bestimmte Regeln sollten wirklich unter die Lupe genommen werden,
Äh also ich kann in jetzt Ihnen jetzt nicht sagen, ob wir eher für eine vollständige Kartierung äh gehen oder ob wir bestimmte Zonen wirklich ähm.
Höher auflösend.
Dann schauen.
Okay, das entscheidet sich, dann ist ja auch immer ein permanentes Abwägen äh.
Permanent, ja, mit der Wissenschaft, mit der Gemeinschaft.
Und das ist ja dann im Prinzip auch genau das, was äh so ein Mission-Manager dann wahrscheinlich auch äh primär leisten muss hier am äh Izak. Dieses Abwägen der Anforderungen, der Wissenschaft äh und der entsprechenden Anforderungen an die an die Missionssteuerung.
So jeder hat seine Ziele und äh das muss man natürlich verstehen. Ähm wenn man als Mission Manager arbeiten will, ähm
die Safety äh des Space Crafts ist natürlich ganz wichtig und äh traditionell hat man immer so
Wissenschaftler, die wollen natürlich mehr ähm mit der Sonde machen und ähm die Ingenieure, die versuchen natürlich etwas konservativer zu sein und äh natürlich sind beide Standpunkte richtig und ähm da muss man,
Sich entscheiden, je nachdem,
welche Objektive man erreichen will. Ähm ich sehe das natürlich als als die schwierigste Arbeit. Ich stelle mir die ganze Mission vor wie ein Schiff, ja. Ähm,
die ein Shift, wo man versurht, äh unerforschte gegen gegen äh ähm erforschen will.
Und äh ja man muss natürlich gucken, dass alle zusammen mit arbeiten, dass wir die Ressourcen haben,
dass wir die Konflikte lösen können und äh ich lege viel Wert drauf, dass man ähm sehr früh ähm das Ganze übt. Wir haben's äh also man sollte ganz früh die,
die die die wahrscheinlichste Probleme äh lösen können, gucken, was auftreten kann und wie wir dann reagieren, ja, damit wir keine Zeit verlieren.
Jetzt ist man ja mit so einem Projekt ganz schön verheiratet. Also das äh wird ja jetzt, wenn alles so nach Plan läuft,
ist ja das äh erste Missionsende, glaube ich, so gegen zwanzig dreiunddreißig ähm angepeilt,
Das ist ja dann meistens auch immer so der Punkt, wo man sagt, naja, bisschen Treibstoff haben wir ja noch und jetzt haben wir unsere Ziele erreicht und jetzt machen wir noch mal ein bisschen weiter, dann kannst du auch, was weiß ich, was da noch drin ist, vielleicht nochmal fünf Jahre länger gehen, ist das realistisch?
Ich würde erstmal ja, zweimal zwei Jahre vielleicht, ja?
Ja okay, gut, ne, also in der Größenordnung. So, das heißt, wir reden dann schon so über die nächsten 12, 13äh Jahre. Wie ist denn das, wenn wenn man sich so so lange auf so einen,
ein Projekt einlässt und dass er dann eigentlich auch gar nicht mehr gehen lassen kann.
Also das sind diese Missionen, die beschäftigen Generationen, ja? Das ist die Erforschung des äh Aus- und Sonnensystems. Ich war als Student bei Galileo,
Bin ich etwas größer geworden und wurde ausgebildet und dann irgendwann jetzt habe ich das Glück, diese Mission für die nächste Generation zu ähm vorbereiten und ähm dann,
zu operieren, ja,
und natürlich werden, das ist diese Miktion ist für die nächste Generation der Wissenschaftler, die sich die Daten noch jahrelang anschauen werden. Ähm aber man muss wirklich das nicht als einziges Projekt sehen, sondern als eine es gibt eine Kontinuität, ja, vom 17. Jahrhundert sozusagen,
ähm bis ja. Ja, aber das das Fashion der Generation von Wissenschaftler sich dann ablösen und äh,
nacheinander an die Mädchen arbeiten, das ist ganz wichtig.
Ja, super. Ich glaube, dann haben wir ähm schon den Kern dieser Mission ganz gut äh,
Gibt's noch irgendetwas, was man vielleicht noch äh unbedingt erwähnen sollte, was diese Mission und ihre wissenschaftliche Bedeutung so betrifft?
Zukünftige schon geplante andere Missionen, die schon darauf warten, hier äh,
als Ansporn für für die nächste Missionsplanung zu nehmen.
Ja ich hoffe das wird ein Schritt sein zu zu einer Landung irgendwann ähm auf einen von diesen Eismann, weil wirklich also ich möchte wirklich sehen ähm,
Zu spät für mich ist, ähm dass wir vielleicht Bakterien oder,
Lebensformen äh entdecken, äh selbst ganz einfachen Lebensformen, ja, damit wir wissen, dass wir nicht ganz alleine sind.
Also ich meine so unwahrscheinlich ist das ja nicht. Ähm es ist ja nun schon mit der Mission gelungen, äh sogar auf dem Titan.
Also dem Saturn Mond zu zu landen,
also auch nicht sehr viel mehr als das. Man ist halt einfach runtergefallen und dann lag man da eine Weile kontrolliert und so mit schönen äh wirklich atemberaubenden äh Bildern und demnächst werden ja auch die Amerikaner äh eine hervorragende Mission mit Hubschrauber starten. Das,
das das wird wirklich äh extrem spannend, überhaupt so das Fliegen ist ja jetzt äh the next big sing, habe ich so den Eindruck, funktioniert ja aufm Mars auch schon ganz wunderbar. Also es ist ja nicht äh vollkommen ähm,
also ich meine, selbst wenn's Zukunftsmusik wäre, wenn die Zukunftsmusik irgendwo spielt dann in der Raumfahrt, aber man kann sich da schon ganz gut vorstellen, dass man so eine Landemission macht und im Gegensatz zum Jupiter, auf den man einfach gar nicht landen kann, ähm sind natürlich diese Eismonde,
Wunderbar, aber mit was müsste man denn da eigentlich landen und welche Vorteile hätte man davon, wenn man das tun würde?
Ja äh ich glaube, der größte Vorteil wäre, dass man unter die Einschicht äh bohren könnte wahrscheinlich, aber das ist wahrscheinlich das ist Zukunftsmusik der ausführlichen Gründen.
Sind wir auch schon bei der.
Erstmal ja wir sollten wirklich gewährleisten, dass wir das nicht beschmutzen oder ja verschmutzen,
Äh und zweitens, dass es äh energetisch gesehen sehr schwierig zu landen. Ja? Ähm von der Navigation her. Das wurde,
studiert, aber das ist nicht nur einfach, ja, äh und ritens natürlich die die sind die Strahlungen ähm die Strahlungmenge äh am Jupiter ist wirklich, wirklich hoch, ja und äh das grillt einfach äh die ganze Elektronik.
Deswegen sind die Mizonen, die wir jetzt haben, wir bleiben nicht zu wir versuchen ähm insgesamt,
nicht zu lange im inneren Jupitersystem zu bleiben. Wir machen unsere Vorbeiflüge und wir sind raus, ja? Und ähm unser Orbit sind so konzipiert, dass insgesamt die Dosis, die wir dann äh erhalten, äh nicht eine bestimmte Grenze übersteigt. Und das ist bei,
bei der Nass Ambition Kleeper zum Beispiel so, dass die nur diese Vorbeiflüge äh machen und dann fliegen raus.
Und die akkumulieren diese Radiationsdosis ähm nur bei bestimmten Zeiten und die passen auch auf, dass die ja nicht zu viel kriegen. Aber das ist wirklich die,
größte glaube ich Herausforderungen von solchen Mietionen ähm ist, dass man.
Gut genug abgeschirmt ist, um bei bei Jupiter äh bei bei Juice ist das so, dass wir die ganze Elektronik der Instrumente eigentlich in so einem Bunker äh an Bord haben, ja, mit äh Beschichtung und äh mit ähm,
Schutz gegen die Strahlung haben. Das macht die Masse des Bischofs auch nicht geringer, ja? Ähm,
für solche Zukunft Musik Landungen auf äh auf Europa zum Beispiel, dass wir natürlich äh eine große Herausforderung.
Schon eher Europa als Becher wäre so der interessanteste zum Landen.
Sagen, je nachdem, was findet?
Okay, das wird sich dann sozusagen alles noch herausstellen.
Vielen Dank, vielen Dank für die Ausführung zur Mission. Das war sehr interessant und ähm ich hoffe auch, dass ich hier in der künftigen Sendung mir immer das Jupiter-System insgesamt auch nochmal genauer äh erklären lassen äh kann, aber.
Zumindest was bei der Isar äh nächstes Jahr dann hoffentlich ansteht. Alles Gute für den Start auf jeden Fall. Ja und vielen Dank fürs Zuhören hier bei Raumzeit.
Weiter und bis dahin sage ich tschüss und.